[La musique]
quand il a commencé le jeu il était de bonne humeur
Hmm
oie
maintenant
osmar un joueur
l'équipe
kan
à Botafogo
wii g joué la moitié si de tous parce que c'est
lyrisme pur suis tabou nourri do touca
Elton que quand ne pas être une fille et juillet
il y avait une foi officielle en gaza tout lire ensemble
avec tout le monde voit et a b et dans sagan déjà
peut frapper le support c'est pas dit c'est que
hier je ne veux pas parler
[La musique]
aaron ammon et papa
c'est amusant de voir de la romance sur la chaîne de télévision express
tutu lei c'est comme le football c'est bien
J'aime bien lire il n'y a plus une loi qui part
Je l'ai utilisé hier et je ne l'ai pas fini, ça fait déjà
la grenade n'avait pas de boule
andre avait le visage
messi était un beau jeu de tante
police de Surica le dimanche à 16h et
ce n'est pas difficile
Garcia dans ce retour de joueur
le futur journal de l'ami le soutien de
monde qui donne la foi